- We're moving more into
clinical aspects of different things...
The latter part of this morning.
But wasn't that fun?
My...
I am very pleased to introduce
Ms. Cathleen Small,
who is a parent-advocate,
and the Medical Outreach
Alliance Coordinator
for the Down Syndrome
Connection of the Bay Area.
She's also on the board of the
Down Syndrome Diagnosis Network,
and works with Bay Area
hospitals and medical providers
to help support families who are welcoming
a child with Down syndrome.
Cathleen,
welcome.
For the first time,
to our podium.
- Thanks.
- Glad to have you.
- Hello.
So apparently the first
thing that I need to tell you
is that I have nothing to disclose,
but that my husband works for Genentech.
But I couldn't tell you what he does.
It's something really,
really,
really dull about
regulatory FDA paperwork.
So anyway...
No disclosures.
So you can see here,
our goals for this presentation.
Let me tell you a little bit about
how I got involved with
Down Syndrome Connection.
I have two children.
My older one is autistic.
And my younger one has Down syndrome.
Both boys.
When my younger one was born,
we got a birth diagnosis at the hospital.
And our diagnosis
experience was not terrific.
And one of the first things I thought was,
"Wow,
this didn't have to be this way.
Someday I'm gonna try to do something
to make sure it doesn't happen this way
for other parents."
So then I connected with
Down Syndrome Connection.
We went to a lot of their programs
and that kind of thing.
And then after a while,
we got to talking and they said,
"You know,
we need to ramp up our medical outreach.
Because we've been in
this area for 20 years.
And there's a lot of
people at the hospitals
that don't even know we're out there."
And I said,
"Sign me up.
That's exactly what I've
been wanting to do."
So that's what I've been doing.
I've been going around to the hospitals,
and to medical groups
and obstectrics groups,
and genetics groups,
giving presentations.
And I generally tailor it
for whoever I'm talking to,
so when I'm talking to doctors,
I usually leave out the
slides that are like,
"What is a trisomy?"
Because they all know what trisomy is.
I don't need to tell them that.
When I'm talking to people
that maybe aren't as familiar,
I give a basic overview.
So today,
because we've got a mix,
I'm gonna give a basic overview.
And Dr. Trotter is
going to speak after me,
in a lot more detail,
since he spent much of his practice
working with people with disabilities.
So I will gloss over it and
if it is a review for you,
I apologize but I will
try to keep that quick.
So here's our little Down syndrome 101.
It is the most common genetic condition,
occurring in one in 691 births in the US,
so we think.
An estimated 6,000 births a year,
and more than 200,000
people with Down syndrome
are estimated to be living in
the United States right now.
This is the most recent number.
Until recently,
they thought it was
somewhere around 400,000
and then they just did a
study that came out last year,
saying it's closer to 200,000.
It's present in all races,
all socioeconomic backgrounds,
equally common in both genders.
And there's no known cause for it.
It's just extra genetic material
in the egg or the sperm.
And it's present from
the moment of conception.
So it's nothing that a mother
did while she was pregnant,
or didn't do while she was pregnant.
There's no blame to be placed.
Sometimes parents feel like,
"What did I do wrong?"
It just happens.
It just is.
So there's three types of Down syndrome.
Almost all of them are trisomy 21,
which is just an extra copy
of the 21st chromosome.
The less common ones are translocation,
where a piece of the chromosome breaks off
and usually attaches
to another chromosome.
Or mosaicism,
where not every cell in
the body is affected.
In trisomy 21,
every single cell in the body is affected.
In mosaicism,
not all are.
And the percentage that are
affected in individuals differs.
Neither of those second two
types is very common at all.
Physical characteristics...
Not every person with Down syndrome
is gonna show all of these.
Some people show more than others.
In general,
most of them tend to have low muscle tone,
hypotonia.
So they're kind of floppy babies
that sort of melt into
you when you pick them up.
They have the epicanthal folds
on the inner corner of the eyes
that give it an almond shape.
Flat nasal bridge.
That's something that sometimes
is seen in the 20-week ultrasound.
I know parents have said that it's
been pointed out to them sometimes
in their anatomy scan.
Small,
or unusually shaped ears.
Excess skin at the back of the neck.
That,
too,
sometimes shows up in an ultrasound.
Not always.
A tongue that protrudes or seems large
compared to the size of the mouth.
So the mouth can actually be pretty small,
but the tongue can be normal sized,
which makes it appear bigger.
And then with the low muscle tone,
your tongue being a muscle,
of course,
it can be harder for them to keep it in
like most of us just naturally do.
They actually have to work at that.
So that's where you get a little bit
of the tongue protrusion going on.
White spots on the
colored part of the eye,
called Brushfield's spots.
Those are actually really lovely
if you've ever seen them.
They make the eyes kind of sparkle.
They're really beautiful.
Single deep crease across
the palm of the hand.
And an extra space between
the first and second toes,
called the sandal gap.
Like I said,
not all of these are gonna show up
in every person with Down syndrome.
Not all are gonna show
up in that ultrasound.
My ultrasound showed absolutely nothing.
But my son does have a very
flat little nasal bridge.
So it didn't show up in there.
Medical concerns in
babies and young children.
So some babies with Down syndrome are
born with absolutely no health concerns.
Down syndrome is the only
thing they're born with
other than a typical child.
Otherwise,
they're like a typical child.
But 50% are born with
congenital heart problems.
So obviously,
this is really scary for parents.
It doesn't entirely have to be.
A heart condition is
always going to be scary.
But we've come so far that
so many of these babies
have a perfectly successful heart surgery.
And yeah,
it's terrifying for the
family to go through it.
But they come out the other side.
the children live a long and healthy life.
Hearing problems.
Semi-common.
Obstructive sleep apnea,
again.
The intestinal issues,
gastrointestinal atresia
and Hirschprung's.
The atresia will show up
before they leave the hospital.
Don't quote me on this,
but I think in virtually every case.
I have heard of people with Hirschprung's
not knowing it before
they leave the hospital.
But it's probably gonna be apparent
fairly early on.
Thyroid dysfunction.
Pretty common.
It often shows up later,
but sometimes in young kids.
My son has had it almost his whole life.
So it does show up in really young kids.
Leukemia is the one
that scares all parents
of kids with Down syndrome,
and if you see kids with Down
syndrome in your practice,
or in your medical office,
you're undoubtedly gonna
see a parent who rushes in
with a child with a rash and goes,
"Is it petechia?
Could it be leukemia? "
Because this is what we all worry about
and this is what we take pictures of
and send them around to our
friends on the internet,
and go,
"Does this look like petechia to you?"
We get over it.
Eventually we realize that some of us
have kids that are just rashy kids,
that get a rash every
time they get a fever.
And it doesn't necessarily mean leukemia.
But I will admit that some of us
are quite paranoid about it.
So you will probably hear about it.
Nursing and feeding difficulties.
Also very common.
But not insurmountable.
There are a lot of kids with Down syndrome
who are able to successfully breastfeed.
For most,
it does take some work.
And there are lactation consultants
that are skilled in teaching the parents
how to work with this.
A lot of it has to do with
the low muscle tone in the mouth.
It's hard for them to form that
good suction with the breast when
they're trying to breastfeed.
And it just takes time.
It takes building up that muscle tone,
building up the endurance.
A lot of them are very sleepy babies,
especially if they have a heart condition.
And they fall asleep while
nursing all the time.
But if a parent really wants to nurse
a child with Down syndrome,
chances are they will
eventually be able to,
if they have the proper support.
In older children and adults,
atlantoaxial instability is an issue
with the cervical spine.
It's not really that common,
as far as I know.
I do not know many people with it.
But it does exist.
And usually they say,
if a child with Down syndrome is
gonna get involved in
something like gymnastics,
or horseback riding,
it could have a lot of impact on the neck.
They should have that x-rayed
and make sure that they
don't have the AAI.
They used to say it should
be done by age three.
The most recent guidelines I've seen said
you can maybe wait till five.
That might actually be better.
So it's seems to be a little bit in flux,
from what I've seen.
Vision problems,
fairly common.
Autism.
We all know that's rising
among the entire population.
And in Down syndrome,
it is more common in boys than in girls.
Just like in the standard population.
It does seem to be a bit on the rise,
in that population as well.
Precocious puberty,
early-onset menopause.
This is not going to happen to
everyone with Down syndrome.
But it can happen.
Celiac disease,
not terrifically common,
but more common in Down syndrome
than in the typical population.
So it is something to be aware of
if a patient is presenting with
a lot of gastrointestinal issues.
Dementia and Alzheimer's disease.
Next to leukemia,
I'll tell you,
this is the other thing we all fear.
Because it's a horrible thought,
knowing that you are going to see
your child slide into dementia someday.
My personal hope,
as the parent of a young child,
is that I've got about 30,
35 years before we start
to see signs of this.
And that's a lot of time
for medicine to advance.
So anyone out there in research,
you wanna work on this?
I'm all for it.
So the AAP has guidelines
for the recommended
screenings at children
with Down syndrome's
well-baby,
well-child checks.
Your medical office probably has them.
If not,
Down Syndrome Connection has them.
We can provide them to you.
So the diagnosis can happen prenatally,
at birth,
or in some cases,
several months later.
Birth diagnosis can be suspected,
but obviously they can't be confirmed
until a karyotype has come back.
Sometimes it's pretty obvious.
But you can never know for sure
until you see that nice chromosome array.
If a family asks what
type of Down syndrome
their child has before the
karyotype is concerned...
You may try to dance around it.
But I know that some families,
like me,
are really pushy and wanna know.
It's probably trisomy 21.
And I will tell you
that most parents of
kids with Down syndrome,
before they know,
are like,
"Oh,
well it might be mosaicism in mine.
He doesn't really look
like he has it that much.
He might be."
And that's what they all hope for.
Because if there's not
as many cells affected,
the chances for their child to
have a more typical life seem better.
So...
We all do hope for it.
But the reality is that,
in most cases,
it's probably gonna be trisomy 21.
And every parent is going to react
to the news differently.
Most of them tend to go through that
typical cycle of grief,
denial,
bargaining,
anger,
acceptance.
But every person is different.
Every person handles this differently.
And regardless of when
the diagnosis happens,
the baby's birth should be celebrated.
The one thing that we have
found from our members
in the statewide surveys we've done,
is that the hardest thing
for parents was when
the people around them
acted like it was a tragedy,
instead of,
"You had a baby!
Congratulations!"
And it's a strange thing,
because it's a congratulations-with-that
sort of side note of,
"I know this wasn't actually what you
planned for when you started your family."
But the bottom line is,
people had a baby.
They want to be congratulated.
So prenatal diagnosis seems to be
happening a lot more now,
with those tests that are coming out.
Harmony,
MaterniT 21.
There's a couple others,
I think,
verify.
I'm forgetting the names of all of them.
A lot of parents that we see assume
that those are diagnostics that will
tell them with absolute certainty,
whether their child has Down syndrome.
And they're not.
They're screening tests.
And they're pretty reliable,
as a screening tool.
But if a parent wants to
know absolutely for certain,
they're still gonna have
to do an amniocentesis
to get an absolute answer on that.
So what can you do?
Treat the baby's arrival as a celebration.
We already talked about that.
That's the biggest thing in this.
A baby was born.
It's exciting.
And congratulate,
don't apologize.
Like I said,
most of the parents that we've talked to
have said it really hurt
their feelings to hear,
"I'm sorry."
They didn't wanna hear,
They knew you were sorry already,
they just wanted to hear congratulations.
If the baby's been given a name,
be sure to use the name.
Because it shows that you're
looking at it as baby,
as a person,
instead of as a diagnosis and
that's so important to parents.
Other thing you can do is
use people first language.
I find this one kind of fascinating.
Because having one son in
the Down syndrome community,
and one son in the autism community,
the autism community seems to be moving
a bit more towards using
the diagnosis first.
"I have an autistic child,"
as opposed to,
"I have a child with autism."
I believe they call it identity first,
if I remember right.
But the Down syndrome
community prefers people first.
"I have a baby with Down syndrome."
Not,
"I have a Down syndrome baby."
Tell both parents together.
You would think this one is a no-brainer,
but I cannot tell you
how many of our families
said that they were not told together,
the mother and father.
And I actually wasn't.
My husband was across the room
and I had to say,
"Could you go get him,
please?"
Because I was completely overwhelmed.
So definitely tell them together,
if there's any way possible.
And remember that mothers and fathers
are probably gonna respond
differently to the news.
Every person is different.
But I think we all know that men and women
sometimes tend to process
things a little bit differently.
So you're probably gonna get
different responses from each parent.
Answer questions honestly
and knowledgeably.
So you probably know a lot of the answers
to things about Down syndrome,
because it's so common.
There's a lot of information out there.
But if you don't,
call us and we will help you.
We will get you the answer.
Because we have it if you don't.
I guarantee it.
Allow parents time to
bond with their child.
But check in regularly to
see if they need anything.
We had a lot of parents tell us that they
were pretty much ignored in the hospital
after they had their
child with a disability.
Nobody wanted to go anywhere near them,
and it was super isolating for them.
And recognize that certain statements
may seem judgemental.
So the one we hear all the time,
is people hate being asked,
"Did you have prenatal testing?"
Because they feel that there's this
unspoken assumption of,
"Well if you did,
you would've maybe made
a different choice."
That may not be true.
You may say that with no
underlying meaning at all.
But that's how parents perceive it.
So that question is a best one to avoid,
if possible.
And be aware of the medical issues.
But you can also emphasize that in many,
many,
many of these cases,
the conditions are very treatable.
So for example,
the heart defects that I talked about.
Treatable in so many cases.
Not all cases.
We still see kids die
every year from them.
But they're much,
much more treatable than they used to be.
And the same with leukemia.
It is terrifying.
A terrifying diagnosis for any parent.
But there have been some studies
that have shown that children with
Down syndrome actually respond better
to the chemotherapy and treatment
for leukemia than typical children.
So that's a positive for parents to
hold onto if they are facing that.
And trust parent intuition.
A lot of our parents say that when they
bring up a concern with their
child with Down syndrome,
they're told,
"That's just Down syndrome."
And sometimes it is just Down syndrome.
But sometimes it's not Down syndrome.
I know from personal experience,
my son's thyroid.
I kept saying,
"He's got all these symptoms.
He's all orange."
And he said,
"Well he eats carrots. "
And I'm like,
"He doesn't really eat carrots."
And I said,
"You know he's kind of lethargic."
"Well that's just Down syndrome."
I'm like,
"Okay.
I don't know."
So push and push and push.
It turns out he did have hypothyroidism.
And once we treated it,
he's a lovely,
normal shade of skin tone now.
And a different child.
So it may just be Down syndrome.
It may be an overreacting parent.
But it might not be.
So trust parents' intuition.
At least give it a second look.
What else can you do?
Provide referrals to us
and to the Regional Center.
So I made contact with pretty much every
social services department in
the birthing hospitals here.
And they should have our information.
If not,
we're easy to find.
We have a website.
We have an office in the East Bay...
That's open eight to five.
Monday through Friday.
But if you email,
there's usually people answering email
at various other times as well.
So we are very reachable.
We will also deliver a welcome basket
with gifts for the family
and more information
about the services we provide.
The welcome packets we
have at your hospitals
are pretty basic because
a lot of the families
do not want to be overwhelmed right away.
And we totally understand that.
So they have a very short
informational piece.
A little brochure about our organization
and a card for our new Parent Coordinator
who will meet with them and talk to them.
If they want a welcome basket,
it comes with a handmade quilt,
and some baby toys,
and some clothes,
and all kinds of fun things.
And more information about Down syndrome,
for when they're ready.
We can also provide a
parent-to-parent match.
We try to match people up
that have similar backgrounds.
For example,
if somebody has a baby
with a heart condition,
we will match them with
a parent whose child
has been through a
successful heart repair.
So you can answer questions about that.
That's my little guy.
(laughter)
Isn't he cute?
I'm a little biased.
So what is early intervention?
You probably hear that term a lot.
A lot of people probably know what it is.
Some of you work in it already.
So I'll give you the brief view.
Children with Down syndrome are entitled
to receive early intervention services
through the Regional Center.
At least here in the Bay area.
I don't know if it differs in
other parts of the state and other states.
But here in the Bay Area.
And that includes infant development,
occupational therapy,
physical therapy,
and speech therapy.
We work in conjunction
with the Regional Center.
So we don't provide those therapies,
but we pick up where they leave off.
We have support groups.
We have development classes
that are not specifically OT,
but that continue to work on skills,
like speech skills,
occupational therapy skills,
gross motor skills.
So the actual early intervention
is gonna come through the Regional Center,
but then we pick up where they leave off
and provide more
opportunities for development.
The Department of Developmental Services
has a full list of area Regional Centers
on their website.
Sure,
if you're in the hospitals
or the medical facilities,
you have them as well.
If you do not,
for whatever reason,
we have them.
So you can contact us.
So quality of life.
Worries about a person
with Down syndrome's
quality of life are generally unfounded,
as are concerns that the person will be
a burden to their family.
So this is a big concern parents have.
How is this going to affect our family?
How is this going to affect
the child's siblings?
What is this gonna do to our dynamic?
I know when I had my son,
I really didn't know much of anything
about Down syndrome at all.
And my first thought was,
"Am I still gonna be able to travel?"
Because my family really likes to travel.
"Am I gonna be housebound now?"
Which,
now that he's five,
I recognize that's ridiculous.
But at the time,
as a new parent,
I was totally confused.
So there has been a large-scale study done
by Brian Skotko among
other people out of Boston.
I'm sure a lot of you probably
are familiar with his research.
I believe it was over 2,000 individuals
with Down syndrome he talked to.
And 99% of people with Down syndrome
indicated that they're
happy with their lives.
And 97% like who they are.
Is that not amazing?
Do you think 99% of us in this room
are actually content?
I think it's pretty awesome.
86% indicated that they
make friends easily,
and those who struggled tended to live in
isolated situations where they didn't
have much opportunity for socialization.
The average lifespan for a
person with Down syndrome
is now about 60 to 65 years.
That is a big change.
When I had my son five years ago,
I had a nurse come in and say,
"Oh,
honey,
don't worry.
They can live to be 25 now."
And I burst into tears because I was like,
"You mean I'm gonna outlive my child?"
It was terrible.
She had old information.
A lot of people have old information.
Particularly the advances in heart surgery
have made that lifespan go way,
way up.
Every person with Down
syndrome has unique abilities.
It's really just like any of us in here.
We all have unique abilities,
right?
I'm terrible at math
but I'm good with words.
Same thing with people with Down syndrome.
They're all gonna have their strengths.
They're all gonna have their weaknesses.
And more and more children
with Down syndrome
are becoming fully included in school,
which enhances their success.
They have done a lot of studies that show
children with intellectual disabilities
such as Down syndrome,
that are included in a
typical classroom environment
with appropriate support,
actually at the end of their schooling,
end up a couple years ahead of students
who are educated in segregated classrooms.
So that's a really positive change.
And right now,
the law supports that for kids.
And in California,
you sometimes have to fight for it.
But the law is on your side.
The federal law is on your side.
So it can be done.
So if parents are concerned about that,
the law is on their side.
They need to know where
to go for resources.
They may need to push for it.
But the law is on their side.
And some of us say there's
never been a better
time to have a child with Down syndrome
because there's so much support now
that was not available before.
The early intervention.
The supports in schooling.
The advances in medicine.
So it really is a good time to have one
as opposed to 20,
30 years ago.
Adults with Down syndrome can have
relationships and marry.
They can attend post-secondary schools.
There's been a big movement there.
There's actually a lot of
post-secondary schools,
even in California,
that have programs for adults
with intellectual disabilities.
There's one down in Fresno
that we hear a lot about,
because it's pretty close to us.
They can live semi-independently
or independently.
They can work at rewarding jobs.
They can actively participate
in their community.
And each person with
Down syndrome is unique.
So there's no way,
particularly if you have a brand-new
baby in your hospital,
that anyone can say what that child
is going to grow up to be or do.
Common myths.
Only women older than age 35 are likely
to have a baby with Down syndrome.
Not true!
80% of babies with Down syndrome
are born to women under the age of 35.
And the reason why is because
more women under the
age of 35 have babies.
So more babies being born equals
more babies being born with Down syndrome.
A child with Down syndrome will have a
negative effect on his or her parents.
That same Dr. Skotko study showed that 99%
of parents in that study
report loving their
child with Down syndrome
and the divorce rate
in families who have a
child with Down syndrome
is actually lower than in families with a
non-disabled child.
Which is very cool,
for those of us who have
children with Down syndrome.
A child with Down syndrome will have a
negative effect on his or her siblings.
Also false.
97% of siblings of
people with Down syndrome
reported being proud of their sibling,
and 88% think that they
are a better person
for having a sibling with Down syndrome.
I will say,
my two sons are four years apart.
And the bond between them is incredible.
My younger one is the
one with Down syndrome.
And my older son is his biggest protector,
his biggest fan.
He loves everything about him.
I don't think he really
sees the Down syndrome.
He knows that Sam has it,
and he knows that it impacts
the way he learns things.
But it doesn't matter to him.
It's just his brother.
And it's a wonderful relationship
and we see that in so
many of our families.
People with Down syndrome
are always happy.
So I had to put in this picture of my son,
who does not like to wear hats.
(laughter)
And my husband had just put
his little pumpkin hat on
and he was really not happy.
He makes that same face if you tell him
there's no bacon in the morning.
(laughter)
So they experience the
same range of emotions
as anybody else.
Anecdotally,
they do tend to be pretty positive,
go-with-the-flow people.
Of my two kids,
the one with Down syndrome is definitely
the more happy-go-lucky.
But he has his moments,
as you can see.
God only gives special
children to special people.
So this one,
I think,
everybody who says this means well,
but we found that our parents
really don't like hearing it.
Because they feel like
they're just ordinary
people who just,
this is how there life is.
And it's fine.
And they're happy with it.
But they didn't do anything special,
that this happened to them.
So what we do.
We have one-on-one parents mentors,
for new families,
which I talked about.
We have support groups for parents,
grandparents,
and other family members.
We have developmental-based classes
for infants through adults.
So at the infant stage,
this really looks like a lot of play,
with the parents talking and we bring
in speakers on different topics.
As they get older,
my son's in the age four to seven class,
and they do art projects.
And they do gross motor activities.
And they dance,
and they do circle time.
And they do calendar.
And it kind of is a
school-readiness type of thing.
And then for our adults,
they do a lot of fun activities.
But then they also do practical skills,
like going out in the community,
and going to the grocery store,
and that type of thing.
We have a school-readiness summer program.
That program is amazing.
My son participated last year
and will again this year.
The speech gains are incredible.
And I mean,
not just verbal speech,
but assistive AAC device,
communication,
sign-language.
They work on wherever the child
has the strengths in communication.
That's what they work on
in a school-type setting.
And then they work with the child's
educational team at their actual school,
so that those skills can carry over.
We actually just won an award
for that program last week.
It was very exciting.
So very cool.
We have an on-site reading teacher.
We have music therapy
for infants and children.
We offer that in the East Bay,
the South Bay,
and the peninsula now.
We have an on-site feeding
and oral-placement therapist.
We have special events
throughout the year,
such as seminars,
training sessions,
camps.
Our Medical Outreach Alliance.
That's what I do,
partnering with the area hospitals
to make sure they have
the information they need.
Our Education Alliance is similar,
partnering with the school districts
to ensure that we can support
our kids in the schools,
and help the teachers understand how
people with Down syndrome tend to learn
and be successful in a school environment.
So what we don't do.
We don't provide early intervention.
That's through the Regional Center.
We can definitely connect people
with the Regional Center though.
We also don't turn anyone away.
Our services are inclusive for anyone.
Family members are always welcome.
My older son participates
in events all the time,
just by virtue of being Sam's brother.
And many,
many,
many of our programs are free.
We are grant-funded and donation-funded.
We have a few programs
that have cost attached,
like that summer program.
But when they do,
there's always scholarships available.
So a family shouldn't feel as if they
shouldn't reach out because
of financial concerns,
because we never turn anyone away.
And there is no membership fee.
Other resources.
Global Down Syndrome Foundation
and LuMind Foundation
are both doing a lot of
research-type work in different areas
in Down Syndrome.
National Down Syndrome Congress has a
wonderful conference every year.
It's gonna be in Sacramento this year.
I'm very excited.
National Down Syndrome Society.
They do a lot of advocacy
work on behalf of
people with Down syndrome and
similar intellectual disabilities.
Down Syndrome Diagnosis Network.
I'm actually on the board of that one.
They are a reasonably new organization,
about three years old.
And they provide online
parent support through groups.
They're a really nice compliment
to organizations like
Down Syndrome Connection,
because 24-seven there
is always someone online.
If your kid has that rash
that you're worried about,
you send a picture to your group
and somebody's gonna answer you,
and answer your questions,
and talk you off the ledge.
Local family resource networks.
They differ depending where
you are in the Bay Area.
But they're all over.
Center for Down Syndrome at
Lucile Packard Children's Hospital.
I'm sure some of you
probably even work there.
We get a lot of families from there.
Charlie's Clinic at UCSF Benioff
Children's Hospital in Oakland.
I know we have someone here from there.
(laughter)
And then the Regional Center
for early intervention.
And that's just my references.
And before I wrap up in 17 seconds,
I just wanna thank everybody here.
I will tell you,
as a parent,
it means so much to have people
that actually care about
kids in the disability community,
adults in the disability community,
and are taking the time to learn
how to make them a part
of the bigger community.
So I really appreciate you all.
(audience applauds)